I think believe it or not in a weird way
if I was a pastor today our church would
be jam-packed we would have so many
people today because
man I don't think churches know how to
tell their stories very well uh forget
about this is not even a conversation
about Jesus God Catholicism Christianity
seven-day Jehovah's you know LDS I'm not
doing a debate part that's another
discussion if we want to have that kind
of a debate that's not for here
I I I I would rather have my kids go to
a Jewish private school than go to a
public school because I list the Jewish
private schools going to teach certain
basic values and principles I'm okay if
my kids go to a Catholic Church I'm
gonna give my Catholic school because I
just want some kind of values and
principles to be taught and I think for
kids today when they're alone and we're
not around because we're not going to be
around them all the time they need to
believe that someone some spirit is with
them that they're not alone I think they
need that today because it's a lot of
pressure today that parents cannot be
you know omnipresent in all these other
places you can your kids are with
somebody else for 10 hours out of the
day you're going to come home you got
two hours with your kids per night then
you got the weekend you don't have that
many hours with your kids so
I think parents are going to need help I
would suggest parents to plug into a
church as quickly as possible find a
pastor you like an environment you like
and I'm not even pitching denomination
just go to plays if you're Jewish go
practice it if you're Christian go if
you're Catholic go practice it because
your kids are going to benefit from it
long term
um
in regards to uh men being men I I think
parents have to realize whoever you
present as a hero your kids will
duplicate and go after so if you present
somebody who is constantly a victim oh
my God life is hard as a hero your kid's
gonna aspire to be a victim because
that's how your kid gets attention if
the way your kid gets attention is by
being sick and you always go to them and
you baby them all the time when that kid
gets older that's how they're going to
get your attention because they're sick
because they're going to get babied by
you I think we need to let people fail a
little bit I think we need to let kids
go through a little bit of Challenge and
times I think putting kids in sports
with a coach that's pushing the kids
sports is very important somebody
kicking their butt is very important I
think boys having strong men around them
if a single mother is raising their kids
figure out a way to have that Uncle
that's tough to be around figure out a
way to have your brother you know
whoever it is to to be around those guys
because if you don't some people are
going to be lost there's no saving them
it's over for everybody else we want to
make movies where the hero is going to
be the capitalist the hero is going to
be a strong man man's man that is in
someone's life and what happens when a
real man is in someone's life and how
that builds their character Hollywood's
your movies are going to matter your
videos are going to matter content is
going to matter books we write are going
to matter right now you know penguin
owns this company called who HQ my kids
read who HQ books we probably bought
five 600 qhq books and they're good
books but in there you will subtly see
messaging from the left that's in the
who HQ I think there needs to be a
competitor to that I think there needs
to be competitor to content this is a
very big task this is not easy it's
almost as if the people that these
subjects matter to the most need to hold
a one-week retreat at a place where they
come together and they say okay listen
we need 100 billion dollars how much are
you putting to put in of your money look
I don't have a uh 10 billion dollars to
put in but I put in 10 million bucks
I'll put in a million bucks my influence
is more from the mic that I have I put
100 million bucks hey I'm going to bring
my file which one do you want to take
I'm going to go into the movie Set how
about yourself I'm gonna go start a
university what are you going to do I
think there needs to be that kind of a
meeting being held because it's and and
by the way I wouldn't be surprised if
that meeting is going to be held in the
next
two or three years where they're going
to be talking about these types of
things but I think the money people the
influential people need to come together
stand up be unified not be afraid and uh
go put their money where their mouth is
and kind of get to work but because if
they don't do that the other side is
very United when it comes on to this
topic so we need some of our power
players to come together and uh get to
work because this is a real issue that
needs the right attention oh I
absolutely invest you simply just
investing in the future of humanity but
no I think you're right and I think the
older I get the more I appreciate the
value of religion and the importance of
it um but I'm going to leave it there I
want to thank you so much for coming on
it's been such a pleasure learning from
you I think you offer so much value so
just really briefly where can people
find valuetainment and if they they want
to come follow oh they can find you can
find it on YouTube they can find it all
over the place I will say this we just
launched a new app called minute where
on Minette the reason why I launches app
connect is because uh years ago a lawyer
had a seven minute call with a lawyer
and charged me 30 minutes for a seven
minute cut and I like it I called him I
said we only had a seven minute call and
he said well seven minutes rolls up to
30. I said no it doesn't so I asked the
Lord I said what do you worth per minute
he says no lower your pace by the minute
I said I'm going to launch an app called
minute that you get to connect by the
minute and you pay by the minute hence
minute so if you want to have a face
time with Andrew Tate for 15 minutes you
can buy it matter of fact one of our
guys had a 15 minute face time with
Andrew Tate put it on YouTube got a half
a million views another guy put it on
Tick Tock got three million views you
can have a conversation with
bodybuilders business people lawyers you
know people who are raising funds so
minute would be the app I would drive to
with today's uh podcast and that's m i n
n e c t you can go to minute.com and
download the app all right I'm going to
download my next straight after this
conversation you ought to get on minute
because I'm sure people want to talk to
you as well I will do thank you so much
absolutely thanks for having me this was
great
foreign
[Music]